there are some politicians that wrote a
letter to the epa and a letter was kind
of ridiculous it seemed like just give
us a summary of like what was this
letter to the epa what is the
significance of them actually writing it
yeah so uh representative huffman uh was
the primary author of the letter and
then there were i believe 22 other
signatories all in
the house i think
and
the letter was short it was two pages i
think it came out on earth day so i
think that was strategic but basically
uh it was a letter to the epa
uh accusing bitcoin miners of uh
basically creating all kinds of
different pollution
so implying the miners themselves were
polluting
and uh talking about noise pollution
talking about toxic e-waste you know
as if bitcoin mining facilities are just
generating tons and tons of you know
e-sludge you know
are they serious when they write this
stuff like do they really think that
they're creating noise pollution well
honestly i think bitcoin mining
facilities that's probably the one valid
you could have which is they're noisy
okay and so as a bitcoin miner you
probably shouldn't put a mining facility
in a residential area but does anybody
do that like i don't think i know of a
single large-scale facility that's in a
residential area or where anybody living
their normal life would hear the miners
are you aware of any there's probably
there's a handful of bad apples i would
say in the big mining space but the vast
vast majority you know obviously bitcoin
doesn't care where it's mined so it's
typically in very rural industrial areas
where it doesn't matter the rest of the
critiques were not really salient they
were grounded and
miss making i think but yeah i think you
know it's hard to know whether the
letter was sincere um it certainly
wasn't very well researched
i think it was mostly posturing
basically saying uh here's a way to
score easy political wins we can beat up
on this industry that nobody cares about
nobody's gonna defend
and uh you know it can be a nice little
earth day uh you know letter to the epa
okay i got a couple of questions you can
answer or not answer depending on how
you feel today uh first is who's funding
this stuff is there like altcoin stuff i
michael saylor a couple of people have
talked about this like are there
competitive and i'll put that in air
quotes projects and founders or teams
maybe even
research areas whatever that are
actually pushing this or like the
politicians going and doing this
themselves so
i don't know if hoffman specifically or
any of the co-signatories of the letter
including aoc issues she signed it um
are funded by altcoins or
any nad that might have an animus
against bitcoin
however there is an explicit campaign uh
funded by
ripple basically to demonize proof of
work and so you know sometimes
uh certain altcoin promoters or other
blockchains prove a stake they will sort
of throw proof work under the bus a
little bit in their
uh public messaging right
but in the case of ripple it's an
explicit uh campaign
against bitcoin or the co-founders
ripple uh chris larson i would say
specifically and so that is an actual
well-funded campaign
with money going to environmental groups
uh to
agitate against bitcoin
uh try and get bitcoin to change the
code uh so to speak which is that's not
gonna probably not happening
so one of the things that i had chris
come on and uh i was very honestly look
we disagree on a lot of stuff right but
i think that uh one thing that we can
agree on is like these technologies uh
at the end we believe they can change
the world for the better now which ones
how we get there all this we pretty much
disagree on almost everything else other
than like hey uh we're both
intellectually interested in like making
the world better whatever that ends up
meaning uh
when i talked to him my read was like he
definitely understands how bitcoin works
yeah like he
i think in in the change the code
campaign they were talking about like
there's like 10 people or something i
forgot what number they used that like
if you go to these 10 people you can
basically change the code it's like i
asked him i was like well who are the 10
people right and he was like well it's
not exactly that way and all this stuff
and so like some of it feels like if you
just say things to the folks who may not
be as up to speed or educated they just
pair at the same talking points and so
like you score uh points with the
uninformed by simply saying things they
read the headline and like that's it but
also
there's this like fallback and every
bitcoin critic that is intelligent
ends up doing the same thing oh i own
some bitcoin
like this is like the classic
right there's people who are venture
capitalists who will just rail on
bitcoin and like oh but i own some right
chris same thing like railing on it but
i own some
at what point is there like a a
threshold like do you have to have a
certain percentage of your portfolio
like what are you thinking about this
they clearly don't you're five dollars
like you own some bitcoin like does that
give you the right to then attack
bitcoin but then fall back and hide
behind like i own some bitcoin well you
should be critical of anything in your
portfolio right you should take a
skeptical eye to your assets whether
that's bitcoin or apple but the question
is whether the critiques are warranted
or not uh in the case of uh of ripple
you know there's a clear he's clearly
very conflicted so it's hard to
decompose the part of the critique
that's genuine from the part that is
motivated by his much larger investment
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time